>> Greg: ACCORDING TO A NEW
SURVEY, 77% OF AMERICAN
MILLENNIALS SAY THEY WILL
LOCALLY VOTE SOCIALIST.
ONE IN THREE OF THEM VIEW
COMMUNISM FAVORABLY.
GIVEN THAT THE TOP SITE READ BY
A MILLENNIAL IS BUZZFEED, NO
WONDER THEY THINK THAT IT ISN'T
AUDIBLE.
WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD BEFORE
WERE WE MOCK MILLENNIALS.
BUT MAYBE IT'S ON US.
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE, WE
BROKE OUR COMMITMENT TO TRANSFER
THE TRUTHS OF HISTORY TO
INCOMING EARTHLINGS.
YOU CAN'T BLAME YOUNG PEOPLE FOR
FORGETTING STUFF YOU NEVER
TAUGHT THEM.
ALTHOUGH SOCIALISM IS A SWEET
IDEA, THERE'S NO COLLEGE COURSE
CALLED INTRO TO SWEET IDEAS THAT
KILLED MILLIONS.
ONCE MEASLES IS NEARLY WIPED
OUT, WHAT HAPPENS?
WE FORGET.
WE START TALKING ABOUT VACCINES
AS AN OPTION.
THEN, MEASLES RETURNS.
THE HORRIBLE EFFECTS OF
COMMUNISM SEEM REMOTE, LIKE A
HANGOVER YOU HAD FROM TEQUILA
WHEN YOU WERE 16.
YOU THROUGHOUT FOR TWO DAYS.
YOU SAID, NEVER AGAIN.
HUMANS CAN FORGET THE THINGS
THAT NEARLY KILLED HIM.
IN THE SAME SURVEY, 72% OF ALL
AMERICANS WRONGLY BELIEVE
COMMUNISM KILLED UNDER
100 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE LAST
100 YEARS.
IT'S MORE.
OVER 100 MILLION PEOPLE KILLED
BY SOMETHING AS MANY PEOPLE
TODAY SEE AS NICE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY THEY
ROMANTICIZE THIS AWFUL STUFF.
JESSE, YOU ARE A FAN AMONG
MILLENNIALS.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL THEM?
>> Jesse: I WOULD TELL THEM
THAT SOCIAL AND SCANDINAVIA IS A
COMPLETE AND UTTER MYTH.
THEY ARE RANKED SOME OF THE TOP
CAPITALIST ECONOMIES IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
THEY HAVE A VERY GENEROUS
WELFARE SYSTEM, BECAUSE THEY
HAVE AN AMAZING CAPITALIST
SYSTEM WITH LOW TAXES AND
REGULATIONS.
SCANDINAVIAN COUNTRIES WERE
GOING DOWN THE SOCIALIST ROUTE
UNTIL ABOUT 40 YEARS AGO WITH
THE ECONOMY SORT OF TANKING,
THEY KICKED ALL THE POLITICIANS
OUT AND THEY/INCOME TAXES.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
REGULATIONS.
THE UNIONS ARE NOT VERY TOUGH.
THERE IS NO MINIMUM WAGE LAWS IN
THESE COUNTRIES.
THEY CAN AFFORD THIS GREAT
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THERE THAT
TAKES CARE OF EVERYBODY, BECAUSE
THEY DON'T GET INVOLVED AND
OVERREGULATED THESE INDIVIDUALS
INCOMES.
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD A
GROUNDBREAKING RESULT IN THE
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY IN
SCANDINAVIAN COUNTRIES?
NO.
ALL OF THE GROUNDBREAKING
MEDICAL RESEARCH HAPPENS IN
AMERICA BE HAVE DONE MY BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE FREEDOM WE HAVE
TODAY.
>> Juan: I WILL SAY THIS.
WE HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO FEEL THAT THE SYSTEM
HAS BEEN RIGGED AGAINST THEM.
YOUNG PEOPLE SAY, HEY, WHY AM I
PAYING ALL THESE HIGH BILLS FOR
SCHOOL?
WHY IS THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM SO
BAD?
WHY ARE THESE NOT GOOD STOLES
DOMINIC SCHOOLS?
THEY DON'T SEE VENEZUELA.
WHAT THEY SEE IS SCANDINAVIA.
THEY SAY, HEY.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE GOOD
HEALTH CARE.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE GOOD SCHOOLS.
LESS INCOME INEQUALITY.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE LESS
OPPORTUNITY, JUAN.
>> Juan: BY THE WAY, WHEN IT
COMES TO A HAPPINESS INDEX, THE
HAPPIEST COUNTRIES ARE THESE
COUNTRIES.
>> Jesse: THEN WHY DOES
EVERYBODY WANT TO MOVE TO
AMERICA JUAN?
>> Kennedy: I WOULD CHALLENGE
THESE
THATE
THAT ASSERTION THAT THEY ARE THE
HAPPIEST IN THE WORLD.
THERE ECONOMIC MOBILITY HAS
ESSENTIALLY BEEN SLASHED AND
SHACKLED.
YES, YOU HAVE TO CUT TAXES.
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
MORE OF THEIR MONEY HOME.
THAT'S WHAT IMPROVES CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE AND ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
SPEND MORE MONEY AND HIGHER MORE
WORKERS FOR THEIR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
THAT'S AN INCREDIBLE THING.
PEOPLE WHO EMBRACE CAPITALISM
HAVE TO HAVE CREATIVITY.
THAT'S THE BEST THING ABOUT
AMERICA.
IF YOU HAVE GOOD IDEAS, YOU ARE
NOT STRANGLED BY A CULTURAL
CASTE SYSTEM.
BY THE WAY, SOME OF THE
COUNTRIES THAT YOU IDEALIZE ARE
ACTUALLY VERY HOMOGENOUS.
>> Martha: IT'S TRUE.
>> Juan: BUT BIG COMPANIES
LIKE GOOGLE AND AMAZON ARE
MAKING IT HARDER FOR SMALL
BUSINESS.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Kennedy: BUT WE NEED MORE
FREEDOM.
BY THE WAY, MY MOM CAME OVER ON
A BOAT FROM ROMANIA.
HER PARENTS TOOK THREE KIDS AND
ONE SUITCASE BECAUSE THEY HAD TO
OUTRUN THE COMMUNISTS.
THEIR COUNTRY WAS DECIMATED BY
SOCIALISM AND COMMUNISM.
WAS A REAL STORIES AND THOSE ARE
PEOPLE WHOSE PRIVATE PROPERTY
WAS TAKEN AWAY BY FORCE AND THEY
HAD TO CRAFT ALL THEIR DREAMS
AND THEY DID THAT HERE.
MY GRANDPARENTS SENT ALL FOUR OF
THEIR KIDS TO COLLEGE, THREE OF
WHOM SERVED IN THE NAVY.
>> Juan: THAT'S THE AMERICAN
DREAM, BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
STATE OWNERSHIP OF MAJOR
INDUSTRIES.
>> Martha: MANY OF THE YOUNGER
PEOPLE ON THIS SPECTRUM HAVE
GROWN IN A PERIOD OF TEN PLUS
YEARS OF ECONOMIC EXPANSION.
THEY DON'T ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE IN AN
ECONOMY DURING THE COLD WAR.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED IN OCTOBER DURING
KENNEDY.
WE NEED TO ACQUIRE MORE OF THESE
CIVICS LESSONS TO CLUE PEOPLE IN
ON THE PLUSES AND MINUSES OF
SOME OF THESE ECONOMIC SYSTEMS.
I WILL RECOMMEND THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO DO A SEMESTER ABROAD,
AND EXCHANGE PROGRAM.
LET'S SEND PEOPLE TO PLACES LIKE
VENEZUELA OR CUBA WHERE THEY CAN
REALLY SEE FIRST-HAND WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO EXPERIENCE THOSE PLACES.
IT MIGHT ALSO BE A GOOD IDEA TO
WORK THE OTHER WAY SO THAT SOME
OF THE CHILDREN IN THOSE
COUNTRIES COULD EXPERIENCE WHAT
CAPITALISM OFFERS.
I LOVE THESE KIDS.
SOME OF THEM ARE MY OWN.
>> Greg: THEY ARE.
>> Martha: YOU NEED TO
EXPERIENCE THE OTHER SIDE TO